[Music]
uh
hello internet welcome to film theory
the show that slowly follows you as you
run away but then pops out in front of
you with the machete of science
it's october and you know what that
means that halloween's already been
canceled due to the unrelenting kick in
the balls that is 20 20. it honestly
makes me really sad since halloween is
one of my favorite times of the year but
you know what i ain't wallowing around
in what we don't have i'm
reveling in what we do have and this
cloud has
itself a silver lining sure we may not
be able to engorge ourselves with free
candy given to us by strangers this year
but we can still dress up and creep
ourselves out all month long by spending
time inside watching classic
spooky movies when it comes to halloween
horror staples i've already covered
michael myers and freddy krueger on the
channel but there's still
one man missing from this trifecta of
terror you all know who i'm talking
about
released on may 9th 1980 the spookiest
season of them all friday the 13th was
the smash hit that would launch one of
the most iconic horror franchises in
history it would be the movie to
introduce the world to the unstoppable
killer
pamela voorhees the vengeful mother who
killed extremely hormonal camp
counselors in her quest for revenge yeah
if you've never seen the original friday
the 13th
jason isn't actually the killer of that
movie and even then his iconic hockey
mask isn't introduced until the third
one anyway when the series starts his
mother pamela is the one doing all the
killings because her son jason drowned
in the lake
years before when lustful camp
counselors were too busy being
stereotypical horror characters to save
him
after his death pamela lost her head and
tried her best to keep the camp
permanently closed but
during the finale of friday the 13th she
literally loses her head via
decapitation
and this is where things get weird weird
er right before the closing credits of
that 1980 film a still 11 year old jason
pops out of crystal lake and supposedly
pulls alice the hero
down into the water alice survives this
attack and in friday the 13th part two
no one believes her story there is no
evidence to corroborate it instead we
meet
jason now a grown man who wears a sack
over his head hunting down more
counselors this confusing revelation
means one of two things
jason either grew into a hulking menace
overnight or
since they never found jason's dead body
in the lake in 1957
it means that he's been living an
idyllic life in the woods and only
emerges again because his mom was killed
in the first place
regardless of which of these two
scenarios is true a legend
was then born a legend who eventually
travels to h e double hockey sticks and
to space before settling down as a
farmer of five leaf plants that'll get
us demonetized seriously the 2009 remake
of friday the 13th goes to some very
strange places
across the 12 installments released
between 1980 and 2009
jason became a pop culture icon his
recognizable hockey mask the ridiculous
kills his
infamous music
and most of all his mastery of the
element of surprise you see one would
think that someone as huge and strong as
jason would be
super slow and he is most of the time
but
then there are those moments throughout
the series where he just seems to
appear in a place unexpectedly it's an
impressive jump scare to say the least
but also an impressive feat of movement
where he seemingly teleports from point
a to point b
like how else could he have done that
move without getting seen
it's actually a debate that's been raged
by fans of the series for decades
can jason actually teleport because
outside of regenerative abilities that
render him basically immortal
and just being really really strong he
doesn't have any other supernatural
powers it's become such a thing that
2017's friday the 13th the game featured
a teleportation option
but is it true is jason voorhees just a
strong dude with an iron will to live
or does he actually have magical powers
that are aiding him in his revenge spree
that my fellow theorists is what we aim
to prove today
coming to the definitive answer as to
whether jason voorhees can teleport
since the friday the 13th franchise has
such a loyal fan base and we didn't want
them to
hashtag blame jason for missing obvious
moments we scoured
f13 message boards to put together a
list of moments that potentially feature
teleportation we then did a re-watch of
the entire series to make sure that we
weren't missing anything
ultimately across the franchise's 12
movies we wound up with
five key moments that absolutely
deserved a closer look
the first is a moment from the fan
favorite part six jason lives
this is the film that introduced the
world to super jason a jason that was
dead
maybe but then awakened when lightning
hits the metal rod stabbed through his
body
in the scene a couple is driving to camp
crystal lake when they're halted in
their tracks by jason
upset that the obviously threatening
masked killer won't clear the road for
them to pass the male character darren
does what any sane person would do
force his girlfriend to drive forward
almost hitting the pedestrian before
getting out his handgun and waving it
around like an idiot needless to say he
dies fast his girlfriend elizabeth
attempts to escape and in true friday
the 13th fashion
falls over her own feet into a puddle
and chooses to stay there while in the
puddle she frantically reaches into her
wallet and pulls out some cash to bribe
jason so he can buy a new machete or
jumpsuit i guess however when she looks
up he's gone seconds later jason lands
down behind her and
finishes her so was it teleportation or
something else
what makes this one easy to debunk is
something that we'll be seeing a lot
throughout this episode elizabeth takes
her eyes off of jason for eight seconds
while searching for her wallet this
gives jason plenty of time to run around
a tree and surprise
impaler from behind why do i know it's
enough time as a test i walked in a
straight line for eight seconds
covering over 40 feet with no problem
also in friday the 13th part 2 we
learned that jason is totally capable of
brisk
jogs and in part 7 new blood he has the
ability to explode through windows with
surprising agility jason voorhees is
just an athletic guy
who only chooses to rush when he wants
to get that sweet sweet kill
it's not surprising that jason would run
to the tree to the right of elizabeth
throw her off her guard and then jump in
the air to land that brutal blow
is it unnecessary absolutely yes but
remember this is also a man who climbed
a tree to drop down from it and land a
brutal
triple decapitation in the end jason
covered like 10 feet max and elizabeth
would have never seen it as she was
digging in her wallet the entire time
friday the 13th part 8 jason takes
manhattan gives us our next moment of
teleportation
it starts with jason reawakening yet
again this time
after being electrocuted underwater
looking for some fresh victims he sneaks
onto a boat named the ss
lazarus haha cute name there guys and
immediately starts bumping off high
school graduates
one of those victims is miles who comes
across jason on the upper deck of the
lazarus boat
after an unsuccessful attack miles runs
and climbs down a ladder
normally running away without tripping
is a smart move in a horror film and yet
when miles gets to the deck below
jason's already waiting many point to
this as jason teleporting i point to
this as jason not skipping leg day
this drawing shows the journey in red
that miles took while climbing down the
ladder
jason in yellow could have easily jumped
down to the lower deck like he's done
countless other times in prior films the
nice thing about being a supernatural
killer is that you have supernatural
knees that can absorb
supernatural impacts plus notice jason's
heavy breathing after that scene
suggesting that he sprinted while miles
simply ran
jason just got himself in some solid
cardio no that's not what's inexplicable
in the scene what defies explanation is
why
miles on a completely open-air boat
decides that the only option he has is
to escape
straight up a ladder he never considers
running back to where he came from or
you know
jumping off the boat into the water no
climb the ladder
sure that makes the most sense i love
how jason just stands there and watches
as miles climbs just thinking
can't believe that worked now my buddy
james from deadmeat says that the latter
climb here shows jason's ability to
teleport guys
did we mention that jason can definitely
teleport now but i gotta disagree there
are seven seconds when jason is off
screen
more than enough time for him to get up
that ladder behind his victim see how
miles slows and eventually stops as he
gets midway up the ladder
jason loves hiding in barns he loves
climbing trees so he can jump down to
nail some awesome triple kills he is a
pro
climber no the much harder to explain
moment from this movie comes earlier
with eva watanabe in it good girl eva is
chased without falling again
by jason into what i lovingly call the
disco lounge
once there she runs around and learns
that all the other doors in the room are
locked and when she looks back toward
where she entered jason
bursts through this is where things
start to get real
teleporty as eva begins to look around
the room and sees jason
everywhere she looks at first glance it
appears undeniable that jason is
teleporting across the room and is using
his supernatural abilities to taunt and
frighten eva
however after further inspection and
research i don't think the teleporting
actually explains what we're seeing here
the f13 fandom page suggests that eva
might be hallucinating to distress
flash blindness panic and the fact that
she spun around the room seven times
before jason entered i'm
actually inclined to agree with this
interpretation but for more detailed
reasons you see
15 minutes before she meets her untimely
end we see eva doing drugs with her
friend tamara
though she initially refuses eva does
eventually take a hit
this leads me to believe that what we're
seeing in the disco lounge is a
hallucination that's a mix of both
fear and drugs notice that there appear
to be two jasons
in this scene the first one is the one
that we see burst through the door and
then move closer to the stage
we see that this jason is breathing
heavily he awkwardly turns his head
towards
something that head turn honestly makes
zero sense based on his position
relative to her in the room
he's not even looking at where he would
supposedly be moving to cut her off it's
very strange but anyway he's a jason who
is in very
active pursuit of his prey the second
jason though
is just standing in front of the glass
panel and never once moves
like not at all he's not even breathing
heavily he's also standing under a
purser sign
now a purser is someone on a boat who's
responsible for all the money handling
the administrative duties the accounting
which is weird considering a purser
would probably hate doing their
accounting in a disco lounge full of bad
80s music but whatever anyway it seems
to me that the way this scene is shot
it's meant to be eva
subconsciously reading the sign as
pursuer which is why she's hallucinating
seeing the guy who is chasing her
appearing under it between the
stationary jason the sign the constant
spinning of the room her being in a
life-threatening situation the added
sensory overload of the loud music and
the flashing lights and all of it within
an
hour or so of her taking hard drugs i
think that this is just a confusingly
shot hallucination scene
and now we go from jason on the high
seas to jason
jason x rejoins the jason saga in the
year 24-55 but before we get there we
make a pit stop in 2010 to see
jason as a prisoner of the crystal lake
research facility
for some reason after decades of murder
and full knowledge of his superhuman
strength the facility heads think it's
totally
fine having only one guard watching him
around the clock
surprise surprise jason escapes and
ambushes the soldiers who entered his
chamber to move him to another facility
while he's murdering him the film's main
protagonist dr rowan is standing outside
the room listening to the
budget-friendly carnage eventually a
soldier knocks down a door in front of
rowan and while she's tending to him the
camera captures jason standing behind
her
breathing like he just sprinted to a
store that was offering free machetes
and self-help books about dealing with
mother issues so how could jason throw a
man
through a door but then just seconds
later appear behind the person
sitting there blocking said door thus
asks team teleport and thus
answers theorist matpat two exits watch
this scene closely after tending to the
soldier thrown through the door
rowan looks directly into the room that
once held jason captive
but earlier when we saw the soldiers
entering that room there was an alcove
looked behind the soldiers as they
marched into the room
there was no door behind them to enter
they had to walk through a door and then
turn
left to walk in towards jason this means
very clearly that it's not the same door
that rowan is looking through later this
is less a moment of teleporting and more
of jason finding another exit to escape
and then stopping to see that whoops
there's another living witness so gotta
go kill her too a hulking murder
monster's work is never done i suppose
and she would have gotten away with it
too if she hadn't gotten too cocky and
tried to taunt him in his cryogenic cell
idiot so with four potential teleport
moments sufficiently debunked we come to
the grand daddy of them all
the most infamous moment that supporters
of team teleport point to as the
definitive moment of inexplicable jason
physics for the entire franchise
in friday the 13th part 8 jason takes
manhattan again wait it's a third scene
from jason takes manhattan
three out of our five examples earl from
this one movie
man maybe that's why this one tends to
top everyone's worst friday the 13th
list
oh wait no no it's definitely because it
ends with him getting toxic waste dumped
on him causing him to melt until he
reverts back to the scared child that he
was when he died
yup that is how this one ends and you
wonder why i did a theory about
teleporting rather than the lore of
these movies speaking of teleporting in
our final and hardest to explain movie
moment we're not just dealing with one
teleportation we're actually dealing
with
two in less than a minute in it jason
while pursuing a man down the street
seemingly teleports to the second story
of a building to throw him out a window
and then
teleports back down to street level to
finish him off in this scene charles
soon to learn the definition of
defenestration
looks behind him to presumably confirm
the distance he is from jason before
entering an abandoned building
a seven second pan up the building later
and we see charles launched out of a
window faster than a religious official
in prague yeah that is a deep cut
european history reference in your video
about 80 slasher victims
welcome to the channel anyway jason
looks out the window and in another
seven seconds is standing over his
target before drowning him in toxic
sewage which apparently just lays around
in convenient barrels throughout the
city of new york so
how did jason get up and down the
building without us ever seeing him
enter or
exit the door that we saw charles go
through and how did he beat
charles up those stairs like jason i'm
just gonna cut to the chase
similar to what we just saw with jason x
there's clearly a second
entrance to the building the biggest
clue to this is when jason appears seven
seconds later to finish off the deed
if you pay attention to the camera angle
jason comes from another direction
relative to where charles first enters
the building look at the scene the
entrance to the building is behind
charles on his right
jason comes in on his left there's
clearly
a second entrance to the abandoned
building we even see
jason leave the window in that direction
had jason been using the same staircase
and entrance as charles he would have
exited the window towards frame
left but instead he goes to the right
presumably to use the entrance that got
him up there in the first place so
here's what's happening in the scene
charles checks to see where jason is
doesn't see him he enters the building
jason shortly behind enters via a second
entrance to cut him off at the second
floor
seven seconds is plenty of time for him
to run up the stairs and we know that
charles is constantly stopping and
looking behind him to make sure that
jason isn't around
jason makes it to the second floor right
before the sprinting charles
charles sees his pursuer in front of him
and decides to pull a trish jarvis from
friday the 13th the final chapter
going for a hail mary escape by diving
out through the window
notice how his silhouette in the window
looks going frame by frame we can see
there's never a change in his momentum
and when his body leaves the window both
of his arms are blocking his face
in all other window jump scares
throughout the series
and there are a lot of them when a
character is thrown through a window
they're not actively defending
themselves against the shattering glass
you'll also notice that there's no
second shadow in the window
if jason was indeed the one tossing
charles out you'd expect to see his
hulking body also silhouetted somewhere
against the glass in the scene
nope charles runs up the stairs sees his
pursuer
jumps out the window misjudging how
painful jumping from a second story
window's actually gonna be
and is rendered helpless until jason
steps in to finish the job the biggest
question i have now is why charles ran
into the building and he had a perfectly
fine alley to run through
i personally have never been chased by
an immortal hockey mask wearing killer
but locking myself in a building seems
like a terrible idea however much like
with eva and miles the fear of jason
is enough to cloud your judgment i
suppose and you see i think that's the
point of this whole episode here i know
that a killer like jason voorhees seems
mythic but when you actually objectively
look at the actions he takes he's
relatively human sure he's a bit of a
bullet sponge and is definitely strong
enough to punch a guy's head clean off
his body but outside of that he doesn't
have any magic abilities
we've concocted these epic stories of
jason giving him teleportation
powers that he just doesn't possess he's
able to kill people not because he's
some supernatural beast who appears and
disappears at will but because his
victims
make mistakes they see him and they
panic
instead of just running and not tripping
they race themselves into corners like
miles and charles
they get cocky like rowan they panic
like eva or
they just don't run in the first place
like elizabeth in the end
jason's deadliest weapon isn't his
machete it's his
intimidation factor and his machete and
the supernatural healing factor you get
the point
anyway it's all just a theory a film
theory and before you teleport away to
another video if you're like me and
you're in the mood for some halloween
scares then check out our sponsor for
today's episode shutter
the world's premiere streaming service
dedicated to all things horror
thriller and supernatural it is in a
very literal sense the netflix of horror
movies
not only do they have staples of the
genre like halloween and texas chainsaw
massacre but also under-appreciated
classics like the changeling
international horrors like the japanese
dark water and
so so many new horror mainstays like
lovecraft's insane movie
color out of space and best of all
unlike other platforms that just throw
content onto them
shutter is actually hand curated meaning
that you're going to get a high quality
movie no matter what you click on that
sentence originally said high quality
scares but then i found the movie that i
actually wanted to highlight for today's
promotion tammy and the t-rex a movie
that is so cringy
so delightfully bad that it can't even
get its own title right considering the
main girl is named
tani in the opening credits you know how
the room and troll 2 are just those
iconic
so bad they're good movies well tammy
and the t-rex deserves its place on that
list
[Applause]
it is a movie where a teenager's brain
gets put into an animatronic t-rex's
body producing iconic moments like a
t-rex trying to call on a payphone a man
getting
flattened like he was run over by a
steamroller like it's some sort of
looney tune and pulse pounding effects
like you see here
and you can watch it right now for free
on shutter
shutter usually has a seven day free
trial but you can get our special offer
of a 30-day free trial right now
by going to shutter.com that's
s-h-u-d-d-e-r
as in fearful tremble and not shutter
the thing that you use to open and close
windows and use the promo code film
theory when you sign up it's gonna get
you those extra couple of free weeks of
horror and considering it's the first
week of october right now that means you
are covered for the entire month so
whether you're in the mood for something
scary or something scarily funny this
halloween
shutter is the service for you i'll see
you all next week for some more spooky
theories